I don't want to delay getting to this
week's hatred mail anymore this is what
hatred mail is the right of the people
to keep and bear hates shall not be
infringed Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom the topical
nature of this week's hatred mail
relates to what's going on with
immigration it relates to quote Mexicans
and arbitrary definitions of what it
means to be a real man I think that's
about all I want to say as far as
introducing it take a listen to this
week's hatred mail the David snowflake
Pakman and his zombie [ __ ] fans are
salty and triggered love Pakman like wet
paper towels wimpy wimpy wimpy LMA
david anyone who is in a socialist is
wrong Pakman deport Pakman ASAP
immigrants cannot be trusted in our
military we need men in this country not
a boy in a man's body like of little
Mexican five feet tall men yeah you know
there is this stereotype that Mexican
men are very small but Mexico in terms
of height is sort of in the middle
worldwide it's not actually a place
where people are that short there's this
caricature ization of the Mayan people
who are significantly smaller in stature
but whatever idea of a man this hatred
has I would encourage you to visit just
about any kitchen at the top restaurants
in the major American cities and tell me
that you're not seeing a manly behavior
going on in those kitchens by
disproportionately Mexican and Latin
American El Salvador many other
countries men and and quite frankly this
idea this is a toxic idea isn't it that
yeah that the stereotypical even if you
imagine them as a shorter stature a
Latin man is is somehow less masculine
indeed these are toxic ideas yeah and
you may be surprised to hear that this
hatred is not being very clear right yet
not one
grants from the American military or
Mexicans in the American military if I
foot tall men would he support
six-foot-two Scandinavian men like was
that okay well they're mostly white so
yes I assume that they probably would
those would be real men also I'm getting
attacked in this hatred mail for being a
socialist even though I'm also getting
attacked this week by all of the
Socialists in our audience who are mad
that I'm not a socialist which I very
clearly explained on Monday yeah but
that clip was like 12 14 minutes long a
hey tree it's not gonna sit through that
fair point that there's no way anybody
actually sat through that if you want to
send a middle finger to the hey tree
'it's use the coupon code hey tree at 40
when you sign up from membership at WWE
at muncom every single time that the
coupon code hey tree at 40 is used 21
hey tree it's cry just the tears start
flowing so I encourage you to use that
coupon code